[Applause]
[Music]
ethic hedge and Octavius stand on the
edge of a bottomless ravine it's the
only thing between them and the tower
that houses the second of three powerful
artifacts they've got a brief window of
time to get across before the guards
return with hedges fuel gauge on empty
he won't be able to fly ethic across so
the only option is to make a bridge
fortunately the floating stacks of
stones nearby are bridge components
invented by Octavia herself called hover
blocks activate a pile with a burst of
energy and they'll self assemble to span
the ravine as ethic walks across but
there is of course a cache the hover
blocks are only stable when they're
perfectly palindromic meaning they have
to form a sequence that's the same when
viewed forwards and backwards
the stacks start in random orders but
will always put themselves into a
palindromic configuration if they can if
they get to a point where a palindrome
isn't possible the bridge will collapse
and whoever's on it will fall into the
ravine let's look at an example this
stack would make itself stable first the
a blocks hold themselves in place then
the bees and finally the sea would
Nestle right between the bees however
suppose there was one more a first two a
blocks form up then two bees but now the
remaining C and a have nowhere to go so
the whole thing falls apart the note of
power enables hedge to energize a single
stack of blocks what instructions can
ethic give hedge to allow him to
efficiently find and power a stable
palindromic stack
examples of palindromes include anna
racecar and madam I'm Adam counting the
number of times a given letter appears
in a palindrome will reveal a helpful
pattern let's first look at a naive
solution to this problem
a naive solution is a simple brute-force
approach that isn't optimized but will
get the job done
naive solutions are helpful ways to
analyze problems and work as stepping
stones to better solutions in this case
a naive solution is to approach a pile
of blocks try all the arrangements and
see if one is a palindrome by reading it
forward and then backwards the problem
with this approach is that it would take
a tremendous amount of time if Hedge
tried one combination every second a
stack of just 10 different blocks would
take him 42 days to exhaust that's
because the total time is a function of
the factorial of the number of blocks
there are 10 blocks have over 3 million
combinations what this naive solution
shows is that we need a much faster way
to tell whether a pile of blocks can
form a palindrome to start it may be
intuitively clear that a pile of all
different blocks will never form one why
the first and last blocks can't be the
same if there are no repeats so when can
a given sequence become a palindrome one
way to figure that out is to analyze a
few existing palindromes in Anna there
are two A's and two ends race car has
two R's two A's to seize and one e and
madam I'm Adam has four M's for a s 2 DS
and 1 AI the pattern here is that most
of the letters occur an even number of
times and there's at most one that
occurs just once is
what if racecar had three e's instead of
one we could tack the new ease on to the
ends and still get a palindrome so three
is okay but make that three e's and
three c's and there's nowhere for the
last C to go so the most generalized
insight is that at most one letter can
appear an odd number of times but the
rest have to be even hedge can count the
letters in each stack and organize them
into a dictionary which is a tidy way of
storing information a loop could then go
through and count how many times
odd numbers appear if there are less
than two odd characters the stack can be
made into a palindrome this approach is
much much faster than the naive solution
instead of factorial time it takes
linear time that's where the time
increases in proportion to the number of
blocks there are now write a loop for
hedge to approach the piles individually
and stop when he finds a good one and
you'll be ready to go here's what
happens edge is fast but there are so
many piles it takes a long time too long
[Music]
ethic and hedge are safe but Octavia is
not so lucky
continue the adventure in Episode seven
of think like a coder or restart the
journey with episode 1 and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]